first of all fortune uh i'm so so happy
to be talking to you like i'm so happy
to talk to you dude we love you like
we you're just you're hilarious number
one uh and number two i've been watching
you on instagram and you've been taking
in all the toronto
while you've been here like you've been
doing it all i have been i feel like i'm
canadian right now i've been here for a
couple months i've got a couple more to
go and we're walking around and having a
good time going to all the restaurants
we love it
so you had a oh happy belated birthday
that's what i wanted to say first of all
and you got to celebrate here canada day
your birthday tons of fireworks just for
my birthday nothing else
yeah it was great we went to this
restaurant that had this beautiful view
of old toronto it was really cool
everybody's just
so nice here
yeah was it kind of a hassle walking
through downtown being like it's okay
guys it's okay relax relax i know it's
my birthday just everyone go home yeah
we're good
let's just chill out i yeah i was here
for that and then uh gay pride in
toronto as well i've been just at all
the all the fun festivals here there's a
lot of summer music concerts it's a good
time to be in in toronto
yeah and it's going to be a great time
to be in montreal too when you're there
jfl is
legendary and they're celebrating 40
years what does it mean to you to be
there
i mean i started my journey with jfl
started in 2010 with their new faces uh
so now i feel like a veteran uh comic
coming here and uh you know it's it's
one of the biggest vessels in the world
and we haven't gotten to do it in the
last two years uh with with the covid
situation so i'm very excited that it's
back and it's a big celebration and it's
a chance for
all us comedians to see each other it
does feel like a summer camp because
we're always on the road and we never
get to hang out so it's fun we eat
montreal bagels and smoked meat and have
a good time all the best things all the
best things does it i don't know
like what your process is like to get on
stage like if you feel nervous at all at
any point in time but what kind of
feelings are you getting um with the
idea of getting out there on stage
postcode knowing that a lot of people
this will be like their first time out
in years to be able to actually come and
see you in person yeah
well it it definitely has this sense of
um
there's there's this feeling of release
that you feel in the audience where you
can when you walk in you can feel people
being kind of tense there's a lot going
on in the world there's a lot to worry
about certainly and
the comedy show is the chance to just
let that sort of melt away even if it's
for an hour and a half you can feel as
the show goes on the energy that comes
from everybody in the room is so
unbelievable this tour
started a little over a year ago and it
just feels like people have not only
wanted to laugh but needed to laugh in a
way that i've never experienced before
as a comedian so to be able to offer a
little bit of levity to people right now
i think is is it's a really nice
thing to be able to do and it makes me
feel good i need it as well
yeah and you mentioned being out there
with your peers is like it's kind of
like a summer camp thing i mean the best
summer camp ever was like kevin hart amy
schumer justin minaj like do you yeah
who sets do you make a point to go out
and see like do you have time to go
chill on someone else's show i normally
i do when i go to montreal i try to make
a whole week of it when i was there in
2019 i my radio show i do for netflix
and siriusxm we we broadcast there all
week so i got to see everybody and see a
bunch of shows this time i am filming
this new netflix series in toronto so i
don't know my film schedule yet so i
don't know how early
i can even go to see everyone but
as soon as i get the green light i'm
getting in my little rental car and head
out to montreal and i will be seeing as
many shows as possible because i'm a fan
of comedy myself i have a lot of peers
that i really enjoy seeing what they're
doing seeing what they're talking about
um so yeah
i will be hitting up shows for sure
is it also really exciting for you to be
able to see because you were part of the
new faces like you mentioned is it
really exciting for you to be able to
even have the opportunity to see some
new people coming up and be kind of
surprised maybe by talent you haven't
heard of before
yeah for sure and i think this year even
more so because i haven't gotten to i've
been on tour like crazy i've this will
be like a hundred city tour so i have
been
gone doing shows and i haven't gotten to
go to the local clubs as much to see
those those up-and-comers and uh to see
who who these new faces are so to go to
montreal it's uh you know it's the
festival saying here's who we think
is the best uh coming up and you guys
should check them out so
uh you get right to the good stuff and
and they're those shows are some of my
favorites because i get to see these
comics who are being really
very inventive they're telling new
stories they you know make you want to
write better they make you want to you
know work on your craft it's very
inspiring to see the new the new folks
if you sat in on your new faces set from
2010
what would be your reaction now
i don't know
i mean you know as a comic you you hope
that you're always evolving you know you
hope that your storytelling's improving
i i would hope that i would be like okay
she deserves to be here she's funny but
i'm sure i would be watching it with one
hand over my
face just like oh gosh because you know
i wasn't new i was a new comic and uh
you you're just a little green a little
rusty and
and don't have the experience yet uh
that you get
you know 10 years 12 years later of
doing it all the time but i would be
proud of her for at least being there
and
and making people laugh that's awesome
no i i hear a lot of comics talk about
you know
when you're evolving from like that very
first set to who you want to be
a lot of it is just putting in the hours
and getting up there and making yourself
vulnerable and being open to failing i
don't know if there's really a secret
sauce but is there something that anyone
said to you that really worked for you
that was like okay and the light bulb
went on and you kind of figured out okay
this is how i'm gonna do it
i'm trying to think i mean you always
get advice from comics as far as like
there's more road advice like stay at
this hotel avoid this place
this place has bedbugs
it's a lot of that that's a lot of the
advice
um i think emote mainly i just saw my
peers how hard they worked and
you know always seeing them in the clubs
trying out new material and then seeing
their tours come out you're like whoa
look at all these cities they're going
through that always inspired me to work
harder and to you know to grind at it a
little bit
um and
you know you can't help like it's like
playing tennis with someone who's better
than you if you're surrounded by people
that are having success and they're
working hard uh it hopefully motivates
you to to put in those hours too and
like you said it is it is ours you stand
up as repetition it's practice it's
doing it it's writing
you only get better based on how much
work you put into it so
i keep putting the work into it and i i
like to say i'm better than i was in
2010.
that's the house
now with this new netflix special um
i'm curious like when you
when you're getting set to do all your
material for a special like this
how far back do you go is it something
that you work on for like let's say this
is like my year's worth of material and
i'm going to put it on this
like what is it like for you
every i think every set is different you
know it depends on where you're at with
with sweet and salty i have worked on
that material for
parts of it for three years or so
just trying to get it right and i think
i was still developing as a comic so
that took me a little bit longer to find
that voice and to find
that narrative how i ended up doing
spring salty was very much a beginning
middle and end and once i tapped into
that in the storytelling i was like oh i
really i really like that so when i have
been working on this special i
sort of
went where sweet and salty left off and
started telling my life as an adult
here's me as an adult here's what i'm
going through
uh trying to figure out how to take care
of myself my family meeting my now wife
getting married and sharing and that
journey and
uh this set came together a lot quicker
i worked on it for about a year and a
half
and then filmed it and i think part of
that was because
a good chunk of that time i was at home
like everybody else in the quarantine
uh my brain was free of fomo or
you know going out and being distracted
by other things all i had to do was sit
at home and try to stay safe and it
cleared it up creatively and all these
ideas started coming to me faster than
anything i've ever experienced before
and this set just really
came together quickly
that's awesome and could that also be
too like
just the experience that you've had of
how you put things together and figuring
that out as well
i think so i think i think putting
together that first hour i've been two
half hours and then this last hour uh
and then this will be my second hour
just that experience of learning how to
put together that hour special i think
made a huge difference now i
knew exactly what i needed to do and
what it needed to look like it helped
rein in that focus it wasn't so broad
um and so yeah i feel i felt more
prepared for this one like i knew
exactly where i wanted to go
and so we filmed that it'll come out
sometime later this year
uh and now i got to write a news set so
that's the challenge
uh so if you have any ideas let me know
i mean
i'm guessing that just walking the
streets of toronto you're getting a
whole lot already yeah
yeah i'll get some i'll get some
inspiration out here
i'm super curious now that we've been
talking about it what can you tell us
about what you've been working on here
ah so it's a new netflix series um i
think it'll come out sometime next year
early next year um
it's starring arnold schwarzenegger it's
his first
tv series ever
which is very exciting it's a big
action
tv series i mean i've never been a part
of something like this before i'm like a
comedian that does sitcoms and you know
the silly stuff
so it's been a trip being in this world
with like special effects and
all this
explosions and uh i'm
really loving it because i get to also
be the silly one within this action
world so it's the best of both worlds
for me but i'm really i'm digging it so
far the show is fun
and entertaining and i think people are
really gonna like it so it'll be cool to
share that with everybody
uh early next year or whenever i don't
know
also the coolest set of stories ever to
be able to tell people
about working with arnold schwarzenegger
i don't know about you like yeah
do you find it hard to resist like if
you're in between takes being like
whoa
really they let off some steam or like
if you see a helicopter overhead being
like get to the top or like is it harder
is this doing those things when he's
around oh i i do it all the time he's
he's got a really great sense of humor
he he likes to tease people
and he's always like cracking jokes so
he it's very easy to like
crack jokes around him because he
appreciates humor uh so we'll be sitting
there in between takes and i'll look at
them and i'll say it's not a tumor
and he'll
he'll gotta shake his head and laugh
uh so he loves it when we when we tease
him and but you know we're all of us are
just very much like tell us about you
know shooting this film or this film
we're always
picking his brain and and wanting to
know his stories he's been doing it for
so long and knows everybody he was
telling me really neat stories about
milton berle and you know he just he
he's a
has so much information up there that we
just keep tapping into
that's the best that's awesome and hey
maybe after this experience you're going
to be like it's action movies for me now
that's the next step that's what's up
look at this
hey you better put those away watch i
told arnold i wanted to go work out with
him i mean i'm sure i'll be the one just
bringing everybody water but still it'd
be cool to just be in there and try to
do a little like
i love it that's the best awesome
unfortunate thank you so much for
spending the time
my pleasure thank you
i appreciate it